he hecho ya un montón de vídeos donde he
usado palabras como presión o que dejen
de escribir la presión y temperatura
temperatura
y volumen por ejemplo volumen y he hecho
bastantes de estos en las listas de
química y de física especialmente de
física verdad pero incluso en la lista
de química he usado palabras como
energía cinética energía cinética le va
a poner de energía también la palabra
fuerza
y velocidad verdad y ya sabes bueno un
montón éstas son un montón de
propiedades de la materia verdad o de
las cosas en este vídeo lo que quiero
hacer es una distinción porque resulta
importante cuando empezamos a ser más
precisos especialmente cuando hablamos
de termodinámica ya saben el estudio de
cómo se mueve digamos el calor entonces
estas propiedades de aquí a la izquierda
son propiedades del sistema o podríamos
llamar los macro estados del sistema
macro estados
macro estados ok y esto es de aquí esto
estos macro estados por ejemplo déjenme
ser más claro cuando tengo un sistema
digamos un globo lo que es un globo como
éste digamos
aquí está mi globo tiene incluso ha
dilatado
una cuerda así quien estos estos esta
macro estados perdón son por ejemplo la
presión del globo eso recuerden que es
la fuerza por área por unidad de área
tiene una temperatura de este globo y
por supuesto es obvio que tiene cierto
volumen verdad pero todos estos nos
ayudan a relacionar qué es lo que está
pasando dentro del globo o
lo que entendemos por globo no esté
antes de que la gente supiera lo que era
un átomo ellos ya ya tenían ideas de que
ya estaban lidiando con los macro
estados ya podían medir la presión la
temperatura e incluso el volumen verdad
ahora sabemos que la presión se debe a
cosas como cómo que tienes un montón de
átomos verdad que están rebotando en el
interior de este globo ok y sabemos
sabemos que la presión de hecho está
causada
en otros vídeos verdad
nos dice ya hace un buen rato es pero
espero que no se pasen por si no se
acuerdan pero sabemos que la presión se
debe debido a los choques que hay en
estas partículas verdad en las paredes
del globo entonces si tenemos un buen de
partículas en cualquier tiempo bueno
muchos estarán rebotando y chocando y es
lo que esencialmente mantiene la presión
y el volumen también del globo verdad
hemos hablado también de la temperatura
que es más o menos el promedio de la
energía cinética de todas estas
partículas que podrían ser un gas o de
hecho vamos a suponer que es un gas
ideal verdad son átomos de un gas quizás
sean átomos de un helio de neón o algo
por el estilo verdad todas estas cosas
describen los microestados entonces por
ejemplo puedo describir digamos que hay
ciertos números
digamos la presión no es de 5 newtons
digamos vamos a poner que es de 5
newtons por metro cuadrado
ok o algún número en pascal es no sé en
las unidades no importan ahorita en este
vídeo sólo quiero hacer la distinción
entre estas dos formas de describir lo
que está ocurriendo digamos que la
temperatura es de 300 grados kelvin 300
kelvin y puedo decir que el volumen es
no sé quizás es un litro bien escrito el
sistema pero lo he descrito a un nivel
macro verdad ahora puedo ser un poco más
preciso y decir cómo son los átomos y
las moléculas que existen dentro lo que
puede hacer es esencialmente etiquetar
digamos cada una de estas moléculas o
digamos que son átomos verdad del gas
que está contenido en el globo y puedo
decir exactamente en cada momento
digamos en el tiempo inicial
la tomo uno tiene cierto momento okay
cierto momento x digamos y su posición
su posición digamos en tres coordenadas
dimensionales verdad que es x jay-z
y del logo puedo decir que el átomo 2
tiene otro momento digamos aquí estoy
usando la letra griega ropa el momento
digamos que es yo y su posición es un
vector
abc jaja y puedo ir alistando cada átomo
de esta de esta de este gas aja que está
contenido en el globo y obviamente
tendremos un número número impresionante
de átomos verdad es una lista masiva
literalmente estamos dando el estado de
cada átomo en el globo y si hiciéramos
eso estaríamos dando microestados ok
estamos dando un microestado específico
de cada partícula en el globo ahora
cuando un sistema y voy a introducir una
palabra aquí porque esta palabra es muy
importante cuando un sistema está en
equilibrio termodinámico déjenme déjenme
describirlo
y equilibrio
ok hemos hablado un poquito de
equilibrio en los vídeos de química y
eso nos dice cuando la cantidad de algo
que está reaccionando es igual
aparte de que también se está
revirtiendo de la reacción verdad pero
bueno en el equilibrio aquí estas
variables no están cambiando verdad si
el globo está a cierta presión
temperatura y volumen estos se mantienen
y si miramos un segundo después la
temperatura y el volumen y todo lo demás
será igual porque está en equilibrio
ninguno de estos macro estados ha
cambiado y de hecho voy a hablar un
poquito de eso en un segundo los macro
estados para que estén bien definidos
deben estar en el equilibrio ahora
por otra parte digamos cuando cuando el
tiempo inicial es 0 y nos fijamos en los
millones de microestados que hay en esta
en este globo bueno en un segundo
después digamos voy a tener
completamente un microestado distinto
verdad porque todas estas están chocando
y cambiando su momento y están haciendo
un buen de cosas locas que podrían pasar
en tan solo un segundo verdad entonces
en él aunque estemos en equilibrio
termodinámica digamos que las los macro
estados se mantengan iguales los
microestados están constantemente
cambiando y eso es por lo cual en
termodinámica tendemos a lidiar más con
los macro estados y de hecho la mayoría
de la sre de la termodinámica o lo que
aprenderemos en un primer año de química
fue desarrollado o pensado por gente que
tenía un sentido a nivel macro verdad y
eso es algo muy importante para pensar
porque vamos a entrar a conceptos como
entropía y la energía interna y cosas
así
y puedes acelerar tu cerebro de cómo se
relaciona esto con los átomos y vamos a
relacionarlo justamente con átomos y
moléculas pero es útil pensar como la
gente llegó a estos conceptos si están
realmente seguros de que está pasando a
nivel micro verdad solo están midiendo
todo a nivel macro y ahora quiero
regresar a la idea de acá del equilibrio
ok y del equilibrio
porque para poder definir estos macro
estados el sistema tiene que estar en
equilibrio y déjenme explicar lo que eso
significa
si yo tomara un cilindro digamos ok
vamos a tomar un cilindro vamos a usar
este cilindro un bueno
así que hay que estar familiarizados con
este cilindro que voy a hacer digamos
que tiene un pistón aquí adentro eso es
como una especie de piso que se puede
mover hacia arriba y hacia abajo este
digamos el piso del cilindro el cilindro
puede ser más grande pero bueno déjenme
ponerlo así este digamos en el techo
perdón del cilindro y esencialmente
estamos cambiando el volumen verdad
porque podemos digo aquí el cilindro
pude haberlo dibujado de esta forma
algo así
y dibujar así el pistón de esta forma
pero bueno aquí es más claro con el
dibujito un poco más sencillo así que en
cualquier momento digamos que el gas
contenido en el cilindro entre él entre
el techo y el suelo digamos ahí tienen
un montón de moléculas de gas un montón
un montón de moléculas y digamos que
ponemos una roca en el techo de este
cilindro ok digamos que estamos haciendo
esto en el vacío es decir en este pistón
se mueve en el vacío es más voy a borrar
todo esto para que vean
digamos que estamos en el espacio y lo
estamos haciendo en el vacío ok todo
esto que está ocurriendo aquí está en el
vacío toda esta parte esencialmente me
dice que hay nada verdad no hay presión
no hay partículas solo es espacio vacío
y para mantener esto ya sabemos que este
gas está generando ya sabes no está
chocando con los muros con el suelo con
el techo incluso con el pistón ya están
chocando con todo con todo y eso está
ocurriendo continuamente así que aplica
cierta presión ok que está generada por
el mismo gas por su movimiento
entonces el pistón va a ser se sube y
baja verdad debido a la presión porque
están chocando un buen las partículas
digamos que ponemos entonces una roca
ponemos un gran peso sobre el pistón ok
que genera una fuerza verdad una fuerza
que se aplica hacia el gas
y obviamente esta fuerza está sobre
cierta área es decir aplica una presión
exactamente y la presión queda
completamente digamos la presión del gas
se aplica en todos los muros eso es
cierto
en el fondo en los muros en el mismo
pistón
ahora
si evapora mos digamos la mitad de esta
piedra
ok digamos que de repente puf se
vaporiza la mitad de la piedra
inmediatamente entonces el peso va a
disminuir verdad y entonces la fuerza
que está ejerciendo sobre el pistón
inmediatamente disminuye déjenme dibujar
eso quizás debería solo copiar y pegar
esto
exacto copiar y pegar entonces vamos a
evaporar la mitad de esta roca
mágicamente déjenme tomar mi herramienta
de borrador y entonces quitamos la mitad
de la piedra entonces qué es lo que va a
pasar bueno el pistón ahora está
aplicando la mitad de la fuerza verdad
no puede
bueno eso reduce a la mitad la presión
ahora lo hizo tan rápido es decir fue en
un momento dado verdad de repente
desapareció la mitad de la piedra
entonces no esto se va a mover de forma
suave y continua verdad que es lo que va
a pasar
déjeme déjeme usar esta herramienta
esencialmente al de evaporar esto vamos
a hacer que el pistón suba debido a la
presión del gas y después déjenme
hacerlo de nuevo se va a expandir el gas
porque el gas empieza a subir y luego
baja y empieza a oscilar poco a poco y
eventualmente va a regresar a un punto
estable y quizás se regrese verdad se va
a ver algo como de este estilo déjenme
rellenar este cilindro
y esto estará negro ponemos sus paredes
del contenedor
y están entonces si esperamos lo
suficiente eventualmente vamos a llegar
a otro estado de equilibrio donde esta
cosa digamos el pistón ya no el techo
digamos se va a mover ya no va a estar
en la misma posición ahora todo esto se
llena otra vez de gas en este punto el
estamos en equilibrio la presión del gas
será el mismo la temperatura también el
volumen también está en una situación
estable no estaba cambiando de segundo a
segundo así que debido a esto nuestros
macro estados estaban bien definidos los
macro estados
bien definidos bien definidos ahora sí
esperamos lo suficiente esto va a llegar
a otro punto de estabilidad donde las
cosas bueno ya tendrán una medida
distinta pero ahora a partir de entonces
no se van a mover verdad se mantiene
uniforme otra vez la temperatura sea
uniforme
vamos a tener quizás este mayo perdón
menor presión pero va a ser la misma
está bien va a estar bien definido otra
vez los macro estados ahora
justo cuando removí la roca la mitad de
la roca y esto empezó a oscilar por un
tiempo la presión en en la cima en el
pistón iba variando verdad todo esto
estaba como en un estado de flujo no
estaba en equilibrio o bien y en este
punto cuando estamos déjenme déjenme
ponerlo cuando estamos en este punto
todo está ocurriendo de forma muy local
a la piedra se vaporizó verdad de
repente entonces sube y baja y sube y
baja el pistón y aquí quizás la presión
era más baja que en el caso que en el
bueno la presión en la parte de arriba
es más baja que en la de abajo y
entonces este cambio está generando como
dinámica verdad en este estado y sobre
todo cuando estamos hablando de
reacciones reversibles procesos
reversibles y procesos cuasi estáticos
en este punto de la reacción
justo cuando hicimos esto ninguno de
estos macro estados estaba bien definido
no no podrían decirme cuál era el
volumen de este sistema porque está
cambiando segundo a segundo o micro
segundo a micro segundo está fluctuando
verdad no podrían decirme
la temperatura quizás quizás la
temperatura por ejemplo en esta en esta
sección déjenme poner algo aquí era de
algo algún número luego la temperatura
era aquí distinta y podría estar
haciendo un buen de cosas locas no
estaba en un estado de flujo los macro
estados no estaban bien definidos y eso
realmente quiero llegar al punto de este
de este tema no déjenme dibujar un
diagrama ok estamos haciendo vamos a
hacer estos diagramas digamos que este
es el de los ejes x voy a poner
digamos nuestro estado inicial cuando
teníamos la roca grandota en el techo
del pistón digamos estaba bien definido
verdadera la presión y el volumen así
que estaba la presión y el volumen
xilográfica mos estaba lo mejor en algún
punto aquí estaba bien definido
este es el estado 1 déjenme etiquetar
este es el estado 1 ahora cuando evapora
mos la mitad de la piedra entonces
esperamos un momento y llegamos al punto
de equilibrio verdad al estado 2
entonces déjenme poner esto de esta
forma quizás el estado 2 era este
hasta este punto y entonces aquí digo
podría agregar la temperatura como una
dimensión extra pero bueno está
determinado por presión y volumen verdad
si estamos por ejemplo consideran un gas
ideal recon que ya hicimos un buen de
estos vídeos donde decíamos que la
presión por el volumen era igual a n rt
verdad
estas son constantes ok esto es el
número de moles y la constante del gas o
universal no están cambiando si sabemos
pib obtenemos t pero bueno vamos a
hablar muchísimo más de esto en otros
vídeos el punto importante de aquí es
que si empieza en un estado inicial 1
donde la presión y el volumen están bien
definidos y termina en un estado 2
bien definido como llegué ahí y debido a
que esta reacción todo lo que hice fue
súbito ocurrió muy rápido y se movió
luego luego del equilibrio fuera del
equilibrio
no sé cómo llegué del paso 1 al 2 la
presión y el volumen no estaban bien
definidos a partir de que me moví de él
de ese estado verdad la presión y el
volumen la temperatura estaban definidos
no sabría yo cómo definirlos en cada
paso intermedio verdad estaban quizás a
lo mejor cerca del equilibrio y después
se fueron moviendo pero podría dibujar
alguna trayectoria digamos
me muevo del punto 1 al 2 pero a lo
largo de una trayectoria pero no
podríamos decir cuál verdad porque
cuando cuando fuera
porque estas definiciones solo están
bien hechas para los macro estados en
estos en los casos en que estamos en el
equilibrio cuando no estamos en el
equilibrio no podemos definirlos bien
verdad los microestados en cambio si
están bien definidos en cualquier
momento del tiempo yo puedo decir en qué
lugar está la partícula verdad podríamos
tener su posición y su momento y no hay
razón por la cual yo no podría saber
este hacer una gráfica digamos de una
partícula de cómo se va moviendo y
podría decir cómo es la energía cinética
por supuesto en cualquier momento y eso
es muy importante así que los
microestados siempre están bien
definidos los microestados es lo que
ocurre exactamente respecto a su fuerza
la velocidad y el momento de las
partículas mientras que los macro
estados sólo están bien definidos y
debería decir este de este sistema
verdad en el caso del globo del cilindro
este donde se puede mover el techo están
bien definidos cuando el sistema está en
equilibrio o cuando esencialmente dices
x algo fijo el volumen no cambia de
momento al momento y la temperatura
igual verdad de cualquier modo los dejo
con eso hablaremos más de esto en los
próximos vídeos